m afin de vendre aux évacuations selon
emmanuel matheron paris va encore tenter
d'exfiltrer plusieurs centaines
[Musique]
la rencontre prévue cette nuit entre
naftali bennett et thomas hayden
repoussée en raison de l'attentât de
kaboul où première rencontre entre le
premier ministre israélien et le
président américain sous le signe de
l'apaisement pour resserrer les liens
entre les deux ennemis historiques en
toile de fond l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien
[Musique]
la rentrée des classes c'est dans une
semaine si 89 % des professeurs sont en
passe d'avoir un schéma vaccinal antico
vide complet selon jean michel blanquer
l'inquiétude reste de mise le ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui a annoncé
ce matin une pause de salaire pour les
professeurs
[Musique]
je
excellent début de soirée à toutes et à
tous et bienvenue sur rt france pour une
nouvelle demi heure d'information le
chaos continue à l'aéroport de kaboul la
menace terroriste plane et ces dernières
heures deux explosions ont fait en fin
d'après-midi au moins six morts et des
dizaines de blessés à proximité de là où
on lieu les opérations d'évacuation des
afghans voulant fuir leur pays d'après
un officiel de l'armée américaine des
choses seraient responsables de cet
attentat depuis dublin où il rencontre
son homologue irlandais emmanuel macron
annonce que paris va encore tenter
d'exfiltrer plusieurs centaines
d'afghans la france qui met fin demain à
ces opérations d'exfiltration
attention notre beaucoup nous
connaissions ce tous ce risque depuis le
début compte tenu de la confusion qui
règne à kaboul et de l'attention qu'il
ya depuis le début sein de l'aéroport
militaire et les prochaines heures
continueront d'être extrêmement risquée
à kaboul elle à l aéroport pour ce qui
est de l'ambassadeur et des équipes
comme vous le savez non l'ambassadeur
l'ensemble de ses équipes plusieurs
autres françaises français un policier
sont et nos forces spéciales sont sur le
site de l'aéroport aux militaires et ils
ont vocation à quitter le territoire
afghan
dans les derniers vols que nous
effectuerons en fonction justement des
créneaux qui nous seront données par nos
alliés américains et donc dans les tout
prochains jours
au moment où nous nous parlons nous
avons vingt bus
avec
des ressortissants plutôt binationaux et
plusieurs personnes afghanes des afghans
en danger que nous souhaitons pouvoir
rapatrier
plusieurs de ces bus sont dans la file
d'attenté qu'il ya dans la zone à
l'extérieur de l'aéroport et donc nous
sommes confrontés aux désordres chaos
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et donc
nous allons faire le maximum pour que
toutes ces personnes
que nous avons pu prendre en charge mais
qui ne sont pas arrivés dans l'enceinte
de l'aéroport militaire puisse y accéder
et puisse être ensuite évacué vers les
émirats arabes unis et la france ça
représente plusieurs centaines de
personnes en danger
ce double attentat intervient à cinq
jours du retrait définitif d'afghanistan
des troupes américaines chargées de
sécuriser l'aéroport de kaboul un départ
qui incite les alliés occidentaux des
états unis a terminé en urgence leur
évacuation farah milk
la menace terroriste devient réalité à
cinq jours du départ définitif des
forces américaines d'afghanistan
le chaos règne plus que jamais à
l'aéroport de kaboul d'ici la fin de la
semaine les troupes occidentales
mettront définitivement un terme au pont
aérien organisé en urgence par leurs
soins lors de la prise de la capitale
par les talibans toutes nos équipes et
tous les belges qui étaient sur la table
un des leurs proches de kaboul ont été
évacués en nombre peut-être un peu plus
avaler jusqu'à demain soir puisqu'un
partir de demain soir on ne peut plus
procéder aux évacuations à partir de
l'aéroport de kaboul nous avons encore
onze vols programmés pour un départ
durant les prochaines 24 heures
notre intention est de continuer à
traiter les dossiers de demandeurs
aujourd'hui avec le centre de gestion
des évacuations et
la raison de ce soudain retrait
simultané des forces occidentales la
menace terroriste aux alentours de
l'aéroport de kaboul
nous opérons dans un environnement
hostile dans une ville et un pays
désormais contrôlée par les talibans
avec la possibilité très réelle d'une
attaque de drèches nous prenons toutes
les précautions nécessaires
le risque est très élevé
onze jours les forces américaines
auraient ainsi rapatrié près de 90000
personnes
soit un avion au départ de kaboul toutes
les 40 minutes d'après washington d
exfiltration possiblement amené à
s'étendre dans le temps une décision
envisagée par les autorités américaines
après la promesse des talibans de
laisser encore américains et afghans
quitter le pays après le 31 août une
promesse dont rien pour le moment ne
garantit qu'elle sera tenue
[Musique]
la russie annonce 13 morts et 15 blessés
du côté de kaboul la russie qui annonce
également la fin de ces exfiltration
d'afghanistan plus de précision avec la
correspondance à moscou d'entre eux
clairement
l'opération d'évacuation des
ressortissants russes mais aussi
d'autres pays est dorénavant terminé les
deux derniers avions de transport
militaires en provenance d'afghanistan
ont atterri un peu plus tôt dans la
journée sur une base militaire de la
région de moscou au final ce sont pas
moins de 500 personnes qui ont ainsi été
rapatriés concernant la reconnaissance
des talibans le kremlin a pris acte de
la prise de contrôle quasi généralisée
du pays mais attend toujours avant de se
prononcer
en effet nous pensons que la domination
des talibans en afghanistan
c'est à dire de facto l'accession au
pouvoir des talibans et la prise de
contrôle d'une grande partie du
territoire afghan est un fait accompli
dans le même temps nous pensons que bien
sûr il faudra surveiller très
attentivement les prochains actes des
talibans en termes de maintien de
l'ordre et de sécurité tout d'abord des
citoyens du pays ce qui est d'une
importance primordiale pour nous ainsi
que les diplomates russes et des agents
des missions diplomatiques
c'est ça la priorité en ce moment
tout d'abord il faut voir comment cette
domination des talibans en afghanistan
s'incarnera dans la réalité
la russie temporis donc pour le moment
mais moscou a rappelé qu'il était
important de continuer à communiquer
échanger avec les autres grandes
puissances en particulier les états unis
pour traiter de la question afghane
autre dossier outre l'afghanistan pour
la diplomatie russe les relations de
moscou avec budapest vienne et rome le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
poursuit sa tournée en europe de l'ouest
en italie où se trouvent nos envoyés
spéciaux monnaies hamoud alors et
renault parquet
à mona l'italie n'est pas le premier
pays visité cette semaine par sergueï
lavrov
il exactement c'est une tournée
européenne qui s'achève pour le chef de
la diplomatie russe en italie après des
visites en hongrie et en autriche
ces êtres dernière étape est l'occasion
de renforcer les relations bilatérales
russo italienne demain est prévu un
entretien avec le premier ministre
italien mario draghi ainsi que des
négociations avec l'actuel chef de la
diplomatie italienne luigi di maio
l'opportunité pour elle les deux hommes
est d'échanger sur l'agenda
international et notamment sur un sujet
brûlant de l'actualité l'afghanistan
luigi di maio elle a confirmé la
situation à kaboul sera au centre à des
conversations dès demain ce sera
également l'occasion d'aborder lé
questions européennes ainsi que
l'implication l influence de l'otan en
europe mais pas seulement il sera
question de la situation en ukraine en
libye ou encore au moyen-orient alors
après cette tournée européenne pas de
visite en france pour consolider est les
relations bilatérales ou même aplanir
les différends entre les deux pays après
un jet set exceptionnel sur
l'afghanistan sans la russie dont le
rôle est crucial dans la région luigi et
10 maiolo ap le ministre des affaires
étrangères a indiqué que le g20 qui se
tiendra ici même fin du mois d'octobre à
rome sera une plate forme multilatérale
pour trouver à des solutions aux
communes à tous les défis qui vont se
présenter
merci mon âme au dès lors pour toutes
ces précisions en direct de rome merci
également à renault parquet qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra
la rencontre à washington entre naftali
bennett et joe biden était attendu pour
minuit heure de paris elle est
finalement repoussée en raison de
l'attentât à l'aéroport de kaboul un
premier face à face entre le président
américain et le premier ministre
israélien avec en filigrane la question
du retour des etats unis dans l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien arthur bisquert
avec quentin mauclair
première visite d'état pour naftali
bennett le premier ministre israélien se
trouve depuis ce mercredi à washington
où il s'est entretenu avec des hauts
responsables américains dont anthony
blinken le secrétaire d'état au menu de
ce dialogue l'épineux dossier du
nucléaire iranien
tel aviv sous et réaffirmé sa fermeté à
l'encontre de téhéran
nous espérons j'apporte d'israël un
nouvel esprit un esprit de personnes qui
ont parfois des opinions différentes et
mais qui travaillent ensemble dans la
coopération et la bonne volonté et c'est
le même esprit que je veux apporter à
nos relations de coopération de bonne
volonté d'amitié good work
nous allons discuter de plusieurs
questions et principalement de la
manière de repousser et de freiner les
efforts de l'iran pour dominer la région
une préoccupation israélienne entendu
est partagé par les états unis
la sécurité d'israël est et sera
toujours inébranlable et nous sommes
impatients de relever tous les défis
auxquels nous sommes confrontés en
particulier la sécurité régionale et les
profondes préoccupations que nous
partageons au sujet de l'iran et du rôle
qu'ils jouent dans la région y compris
son programme nucléaire
nouvelle étape de ce voyage aux etats
unis pour naftali bennet ce jeudi la
rencontre avec joe biden le premier
ministre israélien va s'entretenir pour
la première fois avec le président
américain
avec comme objectif de partager un
nouvel esprit de collaboration entre les
deux pays les relations étaient très
resserrée lors des mandats de leurs
dirigeants précédents donald trump et
benyamine miaou cette fois-ci joe biden
doit désormais choisir une ligne
directrice pour ses futures relations
avec l'état hébreu le spectre du conflit
israélo-palestinien planera au dessus de
la rencontre de ce jeudi en jeu
notamment le sort du consulat général
est chargé des affaires palestiniennes à
jérusalem fermé par donald trump si joe
biden affiche sa volonté de rouvrir
cette antenne diplomatique détention
pourrait voir le jour entre les deux
pays enfin joe biden et naftali bennet
vont échanger également sur la situation
sanitaire le premier ministre israélien
a annoncé qu'ils allaient partager les
connaissances dont son pays dispose sur
l'injection d'une troisième dose de
vaccin d'ores et déjà en place en israël
entre fermeté et partenariats le chef
d'état américain devra trouver le bon
équilibre pour préserver l'alliance
stratégique entre les deux pays
un préserver a également l'alliance et
renforcer l'amitié entre paris et dublin
déplacement cet après midi des manuels
maquereau en irlande l'occasion
d'évoquer des dossiers brûlants comme le
break site ou encore les taux
d'imposition pour sa rentrée européenne
valentin carpentier
il était 10 heures ce jeudi matin
lorsque emmanuel macron foulé pour la
première fois le sol du parvis du palais
présidentiel irlandais accueilli par le
président michael higgins et son épouse
le chef de l'état a choisi l'irlande
pour effectuer sa rentrée européenne
objectif consolider l'amitié entre les
deux pays aborder les retombées du bras
excite et préparer la présidence
française de l'union européenne en 2022
pour cela le président français son
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian ont élaboré avec leurs
homologues irlandais un plan d'action
franco irlandais la france est
aujourd'hui devenu le voisin le plus
proche de l'irlande au sein de l'union
ce qui évidemment au delà des projets
qui existent depuis plusieurs années et
bien démultiplie aussi notre volonté
d'aller plus loin encore
afin que cette amitié entraide se
poursuivent nous adoptons aujourd'hui un
plan d'action conjoint pour la période
2021 à 2025
mais la rencontre a également abordé
deux sujets délicat le premier l'accord
international sur la fiscalité
défendu par 130 pays dont la france le
compromis trouvé en juillet par l' ocde
prévoit de taxer les bénéfices des
multinationales avec un taux
d'imposition minimum de 15 % à l'échelle
globale un projet auquel l'irlande ne
peut qu'être réticente avec un taux
d'imposition des multinationales à 12 5%
sur l'un des plus bas au monde le pays
abrite plusieurs grands groupes de la
technologie et de la pharmacie et
vivrait mal leur départ 6e tour venait à
augmenter
de son côté la france n'a pas
l'intention de baisser les bras
la situation actuelle va sans doute
exiger des changements profonds de notre
modèle économique habituel mais c'est à
l'irlande de décider pour elles mêmes et
non à la france de faire pression mais
je pense que l'accord de l' ocde a du
sens dans le contexte actuel et je veux
croire que nous trouverons ensemble le
bon chemin afin de créer un cadre commun
et un taux d'imposition minimum comme un
framework and to deliver 6000 mots
laxisme
deuxième point sensible la mise en
oeuvre du protocole sur l'irlande du
nord prévu par l'accord sur le break
site un texte qui maintient l'irlande du
nord dans le marché unique et l'union
douanière européen pour les marchandises
un accord remis en cause par le royaume
uni pour faire rééquilibrer les débats
la france cherche donc à trouver un
terrain d'entente avec l'irlande nous
ferons en sorte que les accords qui ont
été signés après de longues négociations
soit dûment respectée
dans toutes leurs composantes qu'il
s'agisse des accords de pêche comme des
protocoles bien connu et donc pour le
dire dans des termes plus familier nous
ne vous lâcherons jamais
des sujets majeurs traitées en moins de
24 heures mais qui prépare emmanuel
macron à la future présidence française
de l'union européenne qui démarrera
début 2022 une présidence qui compte
beaucoup pour le chef de l'état alors
qu'il sera engagé dans sa plus
importante campagne celle de la
présidentielle 2022
et autres campagnes vaccinales avec
l'exécutif qui espère toujours atteindre
à la fin du mois le cap des 50 millions
de primo vacciner compliqué hobbit 19
qui dit rentrée dit reprise du rituel du
jeudi soir ligue et veyran à faire un
point sur la situation épidémique en
france les circulations du quran à virus
a diminué de 15% en une semaine d'après
le ministre de la santé pour qui le pire
a été évité
l'audi et la firme devant vous qui nous
n'avions pas pu compter sur un vaccin si
nous n'avions pas mener une vaste
campagne de vaccination de toute la
population vaccinable c'est-à-dire âgés
de 12 ans et plus la quatrième vague
aurait pu être la pire des vagues et que
nous ayons connue elle aurait pu
entraîner des dizaines de millier de
contaminations supplémentaires chaque
jour des cas graves en masse parce que
le virus plus contagieux peut se
diffuser à une vitesse folle et que nos
hôpitaux auraient pu être débordés en
quelques semaines nous contraignant un
nouveau confinement au coeur de l'été
autre conférence de presse de rentrée
aujourd'hui celle de jean michel
blanquer air à une semaine d'un nouveau
retour en classe placée sous le signe du
coronavirus le ministre de l'éducation
est revenu sur le protocole sanitaire
dès le primaire les élèves devront
porter un masque à l'intérieur pour
éviter l'apparition d'un foyer de
contamination le gouvernement prévoit de
poursuivre sa campagne de dépistage avec
un objectif de 600 mille tests
salivaires hebdomadaire en cas de
contamination dans le primaire fermeture
de toute la classe pour sept jours
jean michel blanquer requis a par
ailleurs annoncé une revalorisation
salariale des professeurs jusqu'à 57
euros net par mois en 2022
un professeur qui gagnait 1700 euros
nets jusqu'à 2020 va gagner 1869 euros
nets en 2022 bon donc quand nous prenons
les plus jeunes de france cela signifie
qu à 169 euros de plus par mois sur un
an et demi qu'ils auront pu
être créés tout simplement par le
grenelle de l'éducation ce sont des
augmentations substantielles et c'est
des augmentations convocation a continué
et s'agissant du protocole sanitaire
pour la rentrée est il rassurant nous
avons posé la question à jean rémy
girard président du syndicat national
des lycées et collèges
pour se retrouve très compliqué où seuls
les élèves
non vaccinés resteront fidèles alors
déjà nous ont été priés la kiné qui
n'est pas vacciné il va falloir se plier
à une déclaration des compas forte de
mon envie d'avoir leurs enfants chez eux
on peut les comprendre et compliqué à
gérer
et on fait que ce qu'ils doivent rester
chez 2k tant qu'ils n'auront pas courant
puisque les enseignants retrouvent en
présente avec les élèves il prouve en
classe donc on risque de se retrouver
dans un film ou à l'école primaire les
kia ko car la classe et en collège et au
lycée dès qu'il ya un cas tous les
élèves rentrent en classe ça paraît
quand même lula j'allais dire par
rapport à la lecture de la pro b aux
antilles le chemin des cours se fera le
13 septembre et non le 2 en guadeloupe
le confinement est prolongée jusqu'au 19
septembre en raison de la hausse des
nouveaux cadres comme les 19 pompes
funèbres et cimetières sont débordés les
familles doivent parfois patienter
plusieurs semaines pour inhumer leurs
proches décédés du corona virus pour
daniel dalin président du conseil
représentatif des français d'outre-mer
ces mesures sont légitimes au vu de la
situation sanitaire critiques sur place
la situation sanitaire en guadeloupe
elle n'appelle vous le faites annie
voulu me lentement
lily patients arrivent toujours de plus
en plus nombreux un groupe
comme on dit dans l'est de la france
khaled que la france envoyait en aveugle
ou n'est pas n'est pas quelque chose de
vain puisque il arrive qu'ils arrivent à
soulager les équipes dia susurre sur
surchargés de travail
depuis lundi l'accès aux grands centres
commerciaux et soumis aux passes
sanitaire mais dans les yvelines le
tribunal administratif en a décidé
autrement
bataille juridique s'annonce les
commerçants continuent à faire appel à
des agents de sécurité pour contrôler le
document les sociétés spécialisées a
débordé par la demande romain pu elle
avec jordi demande
des agents de sécurité de plus en plus
recherchés avec la mise en place du pass
sanitaire commerce et collectivités font
appel à des sociétés pour engager du
personnel supplémentaire
une augmentation de la demande parfois
difficile à assurer pour les entreprises
spécialisées
c'est le cas de la société épi ouest qui
opèrent en bretagne à la recherche de 25
agents soit une augmentation de plus
d'un tiers de son effectif un
recrutement parfois compliqué dans un
secteur déjà à flux tendu trouver du
monde oui c'est compliqué ce qu'on se
rend compte qu'une pénurie ou p2ri
d'agents sur la région
maintenant on arrive toujours à trouver
plus ou moins du personnel
on va dire toujours à flux tendu mais
oui sursis cette mission devait être
amenée à perdurer oui
et toujours en évolution perpétuelle oui
on aurait on va avoir un peu plus de mal
chaque jour et chaque chaque mois qui
passe à pouvoir fournir l'ensemble des
prestations demandées par nos clients la
demande en agent de sécurité s'est
notamment renforcé pour les restaurants
et les salles de spectacle fermée depuis
le 27 octobre dernier ce cabaret situé à
une quinzaine de kilomètres de rennes
prépare sa réouverture en plus d'un
salarié détaché au contrôle des passes
annie terre pour les groupes il faut un
agent de sécurité pour rassurer celui
des clients particuliers une charge
supplémentaire à assumer ça doit
décupler tout en fait
qui plus est ça nous avec le staff qu'on
a déjà à l'intérieur ça sollicite
quelqu'un de plus ce souci au niveau du
un bain du service et c'est donc
forcément il faut décupler les
équipements c'est une charge en plus
pour nous cette vérification
ah c'est pas la masse est pas le virus
ans françois c'est l'organisation
derrière le protocole à appliquer pour
faire face à la demande les
professionnels du secteur de la sécurité
ont demandé au gouvernement une
évolution de la réglementation
ils réclament notamment la création d'un
statut d'adjoint de sécurité
afin de faciliter le recrutement de
personnel
le reste de l'actualité internationale
en bref et en images convoi de camions
pour fourniture des d'humanitaire en
haïti deux semaines après le violent
tremblement de terre et le cyclone qui
ont ravagé le pays insulaire le
programme alimentaire mondial de l'onu
tente d'aider une population en extrême
détresse à plus de 2200 personnes ont
trouvé la mort et près de douze mille
deux cent soixante dix ont été blessés
très endommagé les infrastructures rend
difficile l'acheminement de l'aide sur
le territoire ou par ailleurs le corps
un navire russe continue de faire des
ravages
heurts entre manifestants palestiniens
et gardes frontières israéliens près de
khan younis dans le sud de la bande de
gaza plusieurs protestataires ont été
blessés par des tirs à balles réelles et
des balles en caoutchouc selon des
médias palestiniens les organisations
palestiniennes ont demandé au
gouvernement israélien de lever le
blocus de la bande de gaza en vigueur
depuis plus de 15 ans et permettre la
reconstruction après 11 jours de
bombardements aériens israéliens en mai
dernier
l'inquiétude grandit dans l'est de la
californie après dixie fire un nouvel
incendie baptisé friendly fire fait
craindre le pire une dizaine de
localités ont été évacuées au total 92
grands feux brûlent dans 13 états
américains principalement dans l'ouest
sur l' agence nationale de suivi des
incendies plusieurs petites communes de
montagne ont été détruites et des
immenses étendues de forêt aride
consumer
au brésil des milliers d'indigènes
attend le jugement de la cour suprême au
sujet de leur droit à disposer de leurs
terres ancestrales
ils ont manifesté la nuit dernière en
tenue traditionnelle dans les rues de la
capitale brasilia la plus importante
protestation d'autochtones jamais
organisée dans le pays théo combat
des chants et danses traditionnelles
indigènes ont envahi brasilia la
capitale brésilienne depuis dimanche
près de 6000 membres de 170 tribus
autochtones se sont établis près de la
cour suprême du pays afin d'y faire
entendre leur voix ils dénoncent le
projet de loi gouvernemental qui
pourrait les destitués de leurs terres
ancestrales
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
mouvement contre la thèse temporel et le
projet de loi 490 qui s'ils approuvent
et permettra l'entrée des bûcherons et
des mineurs sur les terres indigènes
c'est pourquoi il est très important de
ne pas approuver la thèse temporel c'est
pourquoi nous nous mobilisons ici pour
que cela ne se produise pas nous sommes
ici pour défendre la vie des générations
futures la vie de nos jeunes de nos
enfants et de nos petits enfants notre
principal objectif aujourd'hui est de
faire en sorte que la cour suprême
puisse regarder avec attention et donner
un procès équitable aux peuples
autochtones c'est ce que nous
recherchons
principale cible désignée de la
contestation lattès temporel les
magistrats brésiliens devront confirmer
ou rejeter cette thèse qui affirme
l'année de la promulgation de la
constitution brésilienne
1988 comme référence pour délimiter les
territoires du pays notamment ceux
occupés par les indigènes problème de
nombreuses tribus ont été déplacées au
cours du siècle dernier notamment sous
le régime militaire entre 1964 et 1985
de retour sur leurs terres originelles
parfois après la promulgation de la
constitution
les autochtones réclament désormais la
protection du statut accordé aux
réserves une hypothèse fermement rejetée
par le président brésilien si cela se
produit ce serait le chaos pour le
brésil est aussi une grande perte pour
le monde nous aurons immédiatement
devant nous des centaines de nouvelles
zones indigènes à délimiter en plus des
pertes pour le producteur rural beaucoup
ont une famille qui occupe ses terres
depuis plus de 100 ans ces terres qui
sont aujourd'hui productive pourrait
cesser de l'être en cas d'acceptation du
projet de loi brésilien les populations
indigènes arrivé après 1988 nous
pourront revendiquer aucun droit sur
leurs terres une option qui pourrait
laisser libre cours à la déforestation
et à l'ouverture de nouvelles mines une
décision importante puisque l'arbitrage
de la cour suprême brésilienne fera
jurisprudence sur l'ensemble du
territoire le verdict est attendu au
plus tôt jeudi et pourrait constituer
une belle victoire ou au contraire un
sévère camouflet pour jaillir dôme sonar
haut à près d'un an de l'élection
présidentielle
c'est la fin de cette édition remercier
notre attention se retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes rester sur arte
france
[Musique]
je
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo l'eau
ou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale bien
évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de kia et
de cet appel d'air justement au
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au temps du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il ya quand
même la liberté je vous remercie d'avoir
un huitième
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse d'industrie
elle est extrêmement contrôlée pourquoi
puisque reverse 50 5 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires à l'état et à la commune qui
sont donc très intéressé au fait que le
fonctionnement soit line ont fait
exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurance loyers d'argent
suspects nous sommes dans l'obligation
de déclarer comment se répartit 100
euros de mise globalement aux machines à
sou par exemple moi j'ai dans
l'obligation de vendre en moyenne 85%
que nous on n'a absolument aucun intérêt
à ce que quelqu'un aille raconter qui
s'est ruinée au casino pas certains vous
pouvez dépenser des sommes extrêmement
importantes allant jusqu'aux millions
d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus on
est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nombre
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir cette pratique obsessionnel
s'impose dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants
comme la condition incontournable une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir on ferait mieux de
faire référence à un passé dont on peut
être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à jamais